hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we have tons of things
to talk about we have steel increases
coming and tons of new information on
the tribute game-mode that was being
talked about for the past a week so it's
not wasting any time let's get right
into this so first up the new weekly
content is new emote which I will show
the video to you right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah it's basically a coin toss for
all the characters you know - a couple
but obviously with their own variation
personal favorite of mine was the air
guitar for the Highlander but anyway
those are gonna be costing 7,000 steel
so get those if you want next up was
they talked a lot about the tribute mode
which I mentioned we talked about the
basic info about trivia mode yesterday
when they released the trailer so click
the card in the top right or it'll be in
the description for you to be caught up
because I don't really feel like
explaining all of that again it's
nothing too big but it is some basic
information that is very well needed
anyway they did talk about a lot more
things that we have yet to know so let's
get started so to start the offerings or
totems will spawn them 30 seconds into
the match similar to the buffs in
elimination and when carrying an
offering you will have a twenty eight
percent speed debuff which is mostly
light most likely to counter the
assassin characters for their fast speed
including shinobi next up is that the
offerings don't have a specific blessing
like I thought they would it's the
shrines meaning I can grab any totem on
the map and place it in the including
one of the three specific strands that
are in our base which could be the
defense buff the attack buff or the
awareness buff if you're carrying an
offering you can you can drop it by
simply getting hit by a light attack so
be aware of your surroundings and
coordinate with the team and a note from
the devs is that the trap feats are
being changed which will definitely help
this game mode which allows you to dodge
through traps by either rolling or
dodging through them there's a little
problem with the traps being too good
obviously blocking off a lot of crucial
areas of the map so now I believe it's
either dodging or rolling I'm not
entirely sure you can now stop that next
up if one team captures all the totems
and gets all three points that team has
to defend all three shrines for a total
of 45 seconds in order to win the match
in them and the match to end but
obviously there's going to be a downside
for these the downside for having these
shrines filled with all three blessings
is that every offering placed in a
shrine you have a three second spawn
delay meaning if you have an offering
and you die it'll be a 15 second respawn
instead of the normal 12 as if you're
being executed and the maximum timer is
three totems and being executed which is
going to total up to about 30 seconds of
Rhys
one time that is a lot of time so if you
have a lot of totems you need to
coordinate with the team and make sure
not to get killed and then the very last
thing for the game-mode is that the
offering holders will always show on the
map so it's cut is kind of like the
Valkyrie buff but obviously without it
if you do hold a offering if you are
carrying an offering you will be shown
on the map it's for the enemies to see
where you are and to pick it up and put
it down on the shrine it's just like
you're reviving somebody it takes a lot
it takes that decent amount of time as
well and if you're hit in the middle of
the animation you cannot hyper armor
through it and I'm pretty sure Shu goki
still stands if he's hit by it with
hyper armor it still goes through him
meaning he can still pick it up either
way that's all about showing you mode
but we have a lot more information to
talk about this dev stream let's
continue on next up is tournament mode
there's a couple things we wanted to
talk about tournament mode they said and
if you guys have ever played tournament
mode you notice on the bottom of the
screen when you look at your ranking of
what you are it shows you the placement
that they wanted it to be they wanted
20% of the player base to be in bronze
20% in silver 30% in gold 20% in
platinum and the top 10% in diamond well
that wasn't actually the case and what
it actually was was 0.5% of the
population was in bronze 8.5% was in
silver 74% was in gold 16 was in
platinum and 1% was in diamond so you
can tell these are very very off so that
what they did is they wanted to
redistribute the ranks basically as
according to what they said 44% of the
current rank tournament pea players will
experience a decrease of some degree of
the rank up to 5 ranks 42% of the
players will experience an increase and
14% of the players will not be affected
at all I was part of the 44% that got
decreased I went from gold 5 to Gold 1
so kind of blows but I got to grind my
ass back up to platinum either way those
are what happens so if you did notice a
dip or an increase in your rank that is
why they're just trying to make the
matches more consistent and there was a
problem especially at the high level
play of diamond 5 where players were
taking 30 to 40 minutes to fight to find
a match just for it to be the same
people because there's not too many
people in that
in ranked to play with so you're always
being matched up against the same person
and it takes too long to find a match
anyway moving on to the next part of
tournament mode is that steel is being
increased for tournament mode now if you
are in the pool or the qualifier and you
lose the qualifier you will get 60 steel
which is a 200% increase if you go to
the quarterfinals and lose you will get
a 70% or you will get 70 steel which is
a 180 percent increase if you lose in
the semi-finals you'll get 80 steel if
you lose in the finals you'll get 90
steel and if you win the entire
tournament you get a hundred steel a lot
of people were complaining that they
didn't get enough steel for their win I
believe if you win you get 50% so an
extra 50 isn't too bad it's a lot better
than what it used to be I think if
you've gotten to the qualifiers and lost
you got like 20 steel so I don't really
get doesn't really matter to me about
the steel I feel that they should
upgrade the rewards but once again
that's them I'm me we all have our
different opinions but either way moving
on the public tested there is a new one
it is starting up next week at September
21st to September 25th is PC only and
they want a lot of feedback on the
tribute mode you're gonna be playing the
tribute mode for most of the public test
to test out some of the bugs and report
it back to the devs you'll also be able
to test the changes coming for the next
big patch in October and it says hinted
to be some really good stuff by the devs
so who knows what these patches are I
personally don't know yeah I don't play
on PC but I'm thinking about getting on
PC just to be able to play in the public
test and share my opinions with you if
not I'll just see what everybody else is
thinking about and judge my own opinion
based on what I've seen so maybe I'll do
a video on that and then the last thing
was is that they just wanted to shout
out some of the workshop people for
coming in to the company behind Montreal
and working on some of the feedback for
the tribute mode the new characters and
changes to the old characters defensive
meta and all that good stuff either way
though that is gonna be the end of the
video thank you guys for sticking around
if you didn't make it this far and like
I said there's a lot of information in
this dev streams sorry if this was a
little bit long either way if you liked
the video please be sure to hit it with
a like and know it doesn't seem like
much but it really does help me out a
lot and if you're new and you
like what I do here I do a lot of
passionless did a lot of discussions all
that type of good stuff hit the
subscribe button and hit the
notification bell right next to it so
you can never miss one of my uploads and
be part of that notification Scott we
got tons of you guys always popping up I
see you in the comments
either way that's gonna be at news
videos popping up on screen it is to the
last two videos I made one was about the
tribute which is the basic thing it
would also be in the description and it
was in the card at the top right at the
beginning of the video and the other one
is a thing that I tried to do a little
bit new I did a montage I tried it for
my first time I don't know if it was
really that great so if you guys want to
check that out give some feedback be
highly appreciated but anyway guys
without that thank you guys for sticking
around and I'll see you all in the next
video guys peace out